[Música]
y vamos directo a santiago en nuestro
programa de hoy conectaremos con nuestra
corresponsal en chile patricia luna
porque el gobierno de gabriel boric
propuso ayudas económicas para hacerle
frente a la inflación en el país austral
los precios subieron a un nivel que no
se veía desde 1994 por eso el presidente
quiere extender un subsidio al empleo
ampliar la ayuda económica posnatal
hasta 60 días y también prometió la
entrega de un bono invierno ahora es el
congreso el que deberá debatir las
propuestas vamos entonces a santiago
patricia buenas noches para ustedes
explíquenos a qué segmentos de la
población están destinadas estas ayudas
pues así serán 75 de los 19 millones de
chilenos los beneficiados con esta ayuda
especial de este bono de invierno el 60
por ciento de las familias más
vulnerables y unas ayudas que como
también señalaban incluyen la ampliación
del bono de posnatal durante dos meses
más hasta septiembre y también las
ayudas que reciben los trabajadores de
nuevos empleos y que ya han beneficiado
a 380 mil personas hasta este mes de
mayo será una ayuda de un bono de
invierno de 120 mil pesos chilenos que
al cambio actual está en torno a los 120
dólares esto va variando mucha velocidad
día a día y el presidente gabriel boric
afirmó que son muchas las familias
chilenas que están sufriendo el alza de
precios y que no como gobierno no pueden
permanecer indiferentes pero que la
recaudación se deberá a un excedente de
la recaudación de otro tipo de temas
este año y que por lo tanto no va a
suponer una mayor presión fiscal también
el ministro de hacienda mario marcel
anunciará próxima semana medidas para
las micro pequeñas y medianas empresas
todas estas medidas destinadas a
contrarrestar la inflación acumulada de
12-5 en lo que va de año en chile un
fenómeno completamente inusual que está
afectando mucho a la economía de las
familias chilenas ya propósito de este
fenómeno en qué contexto el gobierno
está haciendo estos anuncios y cuáles
han sido las reacciones
pues en un contexto de subida récord del
dólar como se acaba de mencionar que ha
alcanzado cifras históricas en las
últimas jornadas sobrepasando los mil
pesos frente a por ejemplo los 850 que
se cotizaba hace tan solo un mes en
también un contexto de un alza
importante de la inflación en un país
que importa el 100% por ejemplo del
petróleo y un 50 por ciento de los
alimentos pero para la presidenta del
banco central roxana el tema en el caso
de chile la inflación tiene que también
un factor interno vinculado a los
retiros de pensiones que desataron una
ola consumista que se pusieron 50 mil 51
mil millones de dólares y 35 mil
millones de dólares que se usaron el año
pasado se destinaron a ayudas por la
pandemia
gracias paula por toda esta información
nosotros continuamos en directo américa